are there any moments between Cloe and
Michael that would have him suffer
perhaps not very happy how much fun
would a show like ours be if that
hypothetically wasn't explored
hypothetically Lucifer 2.0 Lucifer had
told me he had a twin brother nice to
meet you I'm Michael let's talk about
this trailer because oMG Michael is
thinking that I did not expect I mean
I've talked to you guys nobody ever even
hinted at this that this could be a
possibility so when you first find out
about Michael what how did you react
jaw-dropping silence could hear a pin
drop gasping it's one of those things
where you always expect a big bad I mean
from an outside source you know a new
guest doctor knew this but to have our
headliner also personal you need a great
actor and second of all you need know
Abscam and writers and I just it's such
a mind I don't know where but it's also
true to the biblical story which is what
we are I mean Lucifer does have a twin
and so what better most like it also is
the symbolic right you're looking in the
mirror you don't even recognize yourself
or if you you're fighting with your
demon your inner devil on so many levels
it's such a brilliant move that no one
saw coming including ourselves welcome
home
how do you like the mess I made I love
here about how Michael and Max you guys
let's start with you dB how does Michael
impact Lucifer and a meta deals
relationship as brothers and also what
does it mean that Michael and
you are also brothers yes yes yes so
we're all family all big one I'm
dysfunctional family and you know if you
if people go back actually to season
four there's a scene between amenadiel
and dr. Linda and they're trying to
think of names for their baby and one of
the names proposed was Michael yeah go
back look at him in a deal space and
reaction and that will let you know all
that you need to know about how
amenadiel feels about Michael amenadiel
is not a fan of Michael's at all and
we'll learn why in season 5 Michael
comes to the show and Michael causes
some havoc a considerable amount of
drama so it's going to be fun I mean we
already saw some drama over the past
four seasons between Lucifer and
amenadiel though so is amenadiel to
blame for these rifts with his brothers
I mean does he have a favorite twin that
he prefers more than the other I think
it's safe to say that a man is open
first Lucifer over Michael I think
that's I think that we all have a
Michael whether that Michael is a
brother a sister and uncle you know a
cousin we all have that person in our
family sure families are messy when you
shot that episode in season four doing
the baby names did you know that this
was a possibility I did not least you
guys got to say goodbye as far as I'm
concerned Lucifer can well he can go to
hell
Amy for you in the trailer we see that
she's pretty upset that Lucifer never
said bye to Ella so pissed so she's a
right to be angry so when Michael comes
into the picture does she realize that
it's not really Lucifer is she just
given all sorts of sass and not even
thinking twice about it
ella is the dumbest smartest character I
know she
and look at a piece of hair on a dead
body and tell you exactly what position
that person wasn't but she is don't that
that she may or may not be taking off
her - and hitting him over and over
again chest I cannot confirm nor deny
[Laughter]
did take a beating LLC's suffered like
her older brother and to just have him
peace out like that you know she's like
his little buddy so so she feels really
really upset about it she may or may not
have left a couple of bruises
I know Lucifer heals fast but there's
still work some bruises from Ellis from
Ella's shoe on his chest which we shall
when when I talk to I think it was both
of you guys I talked to about but also
I've talked to like Tom and Lauren about
this you guys all said that Lucifer
returns pretty quickly after that season
four finale when does actual Lucifer
come back into the picture to earth this
season is that still true I don't think
that we're allowed to tell you that
Lucifer does in fact come back okay he
does come back for like pain during part
a yes yes yeah yes he does he come back
because of Michael
or does he come back for Chloe I don't
know I I think for some reason I you
know it's it's like it's like being I
feel like we're on the Apollo stage
right now and Aaron and over the that's
giant hook you know just just ready to
like yanked us offstage and just it just
so um I'm gonna I'm gonna stick but no
Aaron is out there in the heaven
overlooking and for anyone wants to know
Aaron is the brilliant publicist who
works for Warner Brothers and so we're
just gonna say that Lucifer comes back
we need him to come back something has
gone terribly wrong and that's probably
all that we can say who catches on fast
as to the fact that Michael is Michael
and not Lucifer I'm a deal ah we got an
answer on that one I'm very impressed
oh we do find out pretty fast yeah I
know
not Ella friggin so clueless but yes I
mean it it was smart
when will Ella realize that she's
constantly surrounded by all these
celestial beings alright we've talked
about this it's times a person actor who
I will say she feels very calm but with
a Mendel she trusts him I feel like I
would love more scenes oh my god wait I
think she just has love goggles for
everyone and that would that hopefully
she'll find out at some point you know
also I just wanted to add because I
think I may be wrong about this
amenadiel might be the second person
that finds out about Michael so I think
there might be someone that discovers it
right before he does and since that
character is not amenity I don't feel
like I can tell you who that character
might be is it a main character it's a
series regular oh you are getting
dangerously close to fire DB you're like
you're so close
this is is Michael the the biggest
villain of the season are there other
big villains that we should expect this
season I think Michael is the biggest we
do have the
wonderful Dennis Haysbert coming to play
God that's not a secret everybody knows
that now and I do have to say that was
something that um I've worked really
hard for Dennis and I had great
chemistry and so it was great to just be
able to get the two of us back together
on-screen which i think is fantastic and
anyway it's and it's not just me I mean
I would you know come to work and I
would hear different members of the cast
talking about their experience with
Dennis I think people are gonna be blown
away there's a specific episode in
general where Dennis and Tom have a
scene which is just heartbreaking
I know Amy and Dennis have also uh one
of my favorite scenes of the season I
won't talk about that
perhaps Amy wants to but everyone has a
has a Dennis story and um he's just
wonderful to work with and you know he
came on set DB and Tom are both there
and they all hugged and I'm always like
watching and running around and stuff
and it just felt like a real family I
can't get over that LS talking to God
and doesn't realize that it's not
talking about it's um if you notice
scenes are really kind of they seem
really like she'll say something off the
cuff to her character and then that
character will remember it and then
bring it up in the last active of the
show like she and Dennis's presence is
undeniable do we have so much time with
God this season because of the brothers
all sort of feuding is that fair to say
that that's the setup
I think well let's just say that let's
just say that God appears for his own
reasons you know it's not so much you
know a feud per se but I think God God
comes for his own reasons I also think
that you know since we did
since we did believe that season five
was gonna be our last season you know
yet
you have to see God and I think the
other fun thing about having God in
season five is it really humanizes these
celestial characters right we see we see
a minute wing we see him you know if we
beginning of the show and ability to
stop time and we see Lucifer's devil
face and and all of a sudden they just
become kids huge larger-than-life
celestial characters become like us like
like kids it's a really fun thing these
characters kind of be schooled a little
bit by uh by Big Daddy G and still on
his I just want a hashtag Big Daddy G
Michael why does he come to earth we
sort of hear him say that he kind of
wants to take over Lucifer's life he
wants all of his things but kind of walk
me through like what are his intentions
I don't think we can say now I don't
think that we can say Michael has an
agenda and it's gonna take us a little
while before we realized what his agenda
really is but his agenda is extremely
dangerous and it's gonna take the entire
family to disrupt Michael's agenda okay
Amy
I cannot confirm nor deny okay how about
this how does Michael affect Decker
Starr and are there any moments between
Chloe and Michael that would have
Lucifer perhaps not very happy how much
fun would a show like ours be if that
hypothetically wasn't explored
hypothetically okay this was a fan
question like I thought it was brilliant
and literally said if Chloe and Michael
kiss
how will Lucifer react I can I can
honestly say that if if Chloe and
Michael kissed you would probably I
would imagine Lucifer would be quite
upset
[Laughter]
let's just say it would be scorched
earth because okay that's fair how what
is being in Hell effect reo Lucifer well
we all know that that time is strange
that in hell so so I think you know fans
should should keep in mind that you know
when Lucifer comes back for him hundreds
of years have passed I believe and so
being down in hell for that long I think
can really really affect a person and
it's affected him it's affected him when
we when we finally do see him again it's
gonna take him some time to repair some
of these relationships exactly it's
almost like someone coming back from war
for a long time there is I think gonna
be some you know it's a little traumatic
for him and there might be some PTSD
that he has to deal with and grapple
with because he'll is hell speaking of
relationships
let's talk about your guys's characters
DB starting with you how's fatherhood
for amenadiel
in season five and how are things I mean
what's going on with him in dr. Linda
and co-parenting I think you know
fatherhood is is challenging amenadiel I
think he based on everything that
happens where we left off I think he's
definitely become the biggest
helicopter parent that we've ever you
know ever saw in our life he's uh he's
really worried on guard all the time
overprotective overprotective as far as
not to Linda I think that they're still
trying to figure out how to do this
co-parenting thing I think most of the
time they're they're on the same page
sometimes they're not I think that their
their relationship to each other and
with each other is complex because as it
is right now it's not a romantic
relationship it started out that way but
it's not that way any longer so I think
they're trying to figure out exactly
what they are to each other and and what
that means I would like to add that
there is a callback scene between a meta
deal in maize that I think the fans are
gonna love Lesley Ann and I love doing
it but that's that's all I can say I
just want to say it's probably a
callback scene to the first season and
the first time that we saw amenadiel in
maize in a scene together okay I feel
like that's gonna have all the pick ends
right now a little bit freaking out I
think so
is there any romance for Ella and 5a
like in the first part of the season
Ella definitely get some finally like
watching everyone else get some dan but
yes ella ella definitely get some we are
going to see our nerdy clueless innocent
optimistic poopy character the happiest
we've ever seen her and the most lost
we've ever seen her there's a particular
scene that was really uncomfortable from
watch and really uncomfortable to shoot
and I couldn't believe it
I couldn't believe the writers wrote
this scene for a character that's just
been really
despite her you know loss of faith and
crisis of faith but she always comes
back we're gonna wallow in fact one of
the darkest scenes we've ever done in
all five years will be an episode that
involves that when you say that I think
of assault is that I mean that's
explored covered this season possibly
it's really it's it's really it's really
sad it's really it's really
heartbreaking yeah how does that affect
I'll if you can even know Ella has a
really strong heart I think but we don't
really see how sensitive she is you take
away her voice and her ability to be her
goofy stuff it's tough because here's
this character who never had a love
interest who never cared what people
think was super pretty who was just in
her whole Lane who was a girl in stem
you know she's like this woman of color
in the sciences no Ellen doesn't lead
with her sexuality no so she just leads
with her brain in her heart and so to
have such a self-confident character
have their world crumbled choices that
she thinks she makes we're gonna start
to see this little angel of a human
wonder a bad person have a seat big
celestial character and be like I'm a
bad person with the bubbly bubbly girl
and in the
is is there a major cliffhanger in 5a
before we get privacy that we yes yes
it's fantastic
oh yeah it might be I think it might be
the best one that we've ever done it's
fantastic yeah so we're going out a
little bit yeah because I think the fans
are gonna go are you serious right now
right there yeah they're gonna have to
wait so that's that's how you know a
cliffhanger is really successful is is
the the anger level that a good type of
anger is there a specific part of the
trailer that fans should pay extra
attention to if they want a hint about
anything major because you know they're
gonna go back and watch for that part of
you guys say yeah I know I just say we
watch the trailer and just pay attention
to Chloe ah because I think that there's
a there's a moment in there I think that
might be a little revealing it goes by
fast
small it's really small but if you if
you break it down you might be able to
at least at least take a guess about
something I don't know if you'll get it
but he might be in the vicinity that's
what I'm gonna do right after this
before I let you go is there a favorite
moment of 5a that you guys are most
excited for for fans to see yes there's
a there's a favorite moment there's
gonna be an absolutely epic fight scene
I don't think that's blowing anything
but there's gonna be an epic fight scene
and what happens at the end of that epic
fight scene is I think my favorite
moment of fighting okay all right you
know I will play some of my favorite
scenes this season are actually between
DP and Rachel because they're hysterical
five eight I think it is that
cliffhanger episode because I get to do
things on the show that I've never done
before and which is very scary for me
just personally as an actor so for me I
think it would I think it's that the
last episode where I mean girl I do not
look cute it's like double chin
happening
I can't surrender to like you know I I
was like I'm just gonna go for it and it
was really vulnerable likewise take Ella
zone so for me that's my favorite my
favorite scene it's you don't know what
you're made of until you're put into
certain situations and we get to see
what Alex character is made of when
she's put in a really really dangerous
situation
[Music]